DANIEL: Could you imagine
if you could ever
capture life in a film.
(CAMERA SHUTTER CLICKS)
DANIEL'S FATHER: I would
like to introduce Daniel.
Hello!
ERIN: As a little boy,
Dan had these visions
about this film
he was going to make.
DANIEL: All I do is I have
a video camera in my hand,
and I believe that life
is an interesting enough story.
DANIEL'S MOTHER:
Not with my open closet!
Dan. Don't video tape me
right now.
(LAUGHING)
ERIN: Over the years,
Dan traveled to 42 countries.
He was genuinely curious
about people.
DANIEL: I feel like
I'm manifesting
the plotline of my dreams.
What's the biggest thing
that we don't understand?
STUDENT:
No, it's nature
and the universe.
ERIN: Daniel collected something
from everywhere that he went,
to remain connected
to that place.
DANIEL:
This is my favorite one so far.
FELIX:
You feel
the shift of reality.
-DANIEL: Run, Felix, run!
-The whoosh!
DANIEL:
DOCTOR: We've had a look
under the microscope,
and this is acute leukemia.
♪ (EMOTIONAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(CRYING)
ERIN:
I remember Dan saying,
"It's linked to my film."
DANIEL: Put yourself in
the position of the character.
They tell you, "You have
six months to live."
I don't want to find out
what happens next,
I want to stay here.
I'm trying to figure out
how to write a twist ending.
Get as close as you can...
Okay. Here we go.
When you are my age,
nothing will be the same.
Make a wish!
Nobody knows
what I'm wishing for.
You will find
the reason for yourself.
It will shine in your life
as brightly as the sun
shines in the sky.
And most importantly,
remember that life is beautiful.
Even when it is sad or scary,
look for that beauty.
That made the whole trip
worth it.